[Música]
en el año 2008
mi padre regresó a bolivia luego de un
viaje que duró 16 años
yo tenía 8 años cuando se tomó la
decisión de que viajar fuera del país
era la mejor solución a nuestros
problemas económicos y así fue
nunca nos faltó nada gracias a mi padre
pudimos ir a un buen colegio gracias a
mi padre tuve mi primer videocámara a
los 14 años y gracias a mi padre soy el
hombre que está aquí frente a usted
pero a pesar de haber mantenido una
comunicación constante con él ya sea por
teléfono por cartas durante todo ese
tiempo mi padre en la casa era un
extraño era una persona la cual amamos
pero desconocíamos y aceptar eso fue muy
duro
los primeros meses después de su regreso
fueron fatal
todo lo que hacíamos decíamos con mis
hermanos a él le molestaba de todo lo
que él ha sido decía nos molestaba
personalmente a mí me irritaba porque
todo era nuevo sus gestos sus costumbres
era como que estuviéramos obligados a
vivir a la fuerza con un desconocido
sabía que como hijo mayor
tenía que ser algo al respecto porque
esta situación está empezando a generar
serios problemas familiares
y yo quería es el camino a mi padre
quería conectar con él pero me sentía
juzgado y me frustraba no saber uno
encontró la forma de hacerle entender a
él cómo es que yo veía el mundo
descubrí que la respuesta a todo esto
era la empatía
verán
cada uno de nosotros es un conjunto de
vivencias y experiencias que nos definen
a veces somos conscientes de estas
experiencias
pero muchas veces no pero existe una
razón una razón por la cual nosotros
reaccionamos a ciertos eventos de manera
particular y ahí está el detalle cada
uno de nosotros es particular ninguno
igual al otro
hay una definición bien bonita de
empatía que dice que la empatía es la
lucha constante por intentar entender
cómo es estar en los zapatos del otro
la lucha constante por intentar entender
pero no basta con solo intentar entender
hay que actuar
y sabía que en la lucha por desarrollar
empatía con mi padre la persona que
tenía que dar el primer paso tenía que
ser yo y tenía que ser que
proporcionaron una situación un ambiente
un espacio para poder conversar con mi
padre sin juzgarnos cuando yo pudiera
contarle mis historias mis éxitos mis
fracasos mis frustraciones mis complejos
donde pudiera yo decirle a él lo que
realmente pensaba del viaje que tuvo que
hacer y como mil veces desearía haber
vivido en pobreza pero cerca de él
y yo necesitaba saber cómo fue para el
vivir en japón por 16 años
como habrán sido los problemas con el
idioma las veces quizás fue discriminado
cómo fueron sus días de soledad sus días
de alegría yo necesitaba descubrir lo
importante que era la familia para mi
padre y cómo muchas veces él pensaba que
estaba destinado a vivir solo
y qué fue lo que hice
pues empecé a llevar mi padre al cine
el gusto por el cine por las películas
viene de mi padre desde que empecé a
caminar hasta que él tuvo que viajar y
del cine era algo que hacíamos con él
exclusivamente
siempre íbamos a ver las últimas
películas
superman las tortugas ninja la historia
sin fin ir al cine era todo un evento
imagínense
la sala llena de gente todos esperando
ese momento mágico en que se apagan las
luces y empiece la película
cuando mi padre viajó dejamos de ir al
cine y de alguna forma
mi madre heredó a la fuerza esta cosa
significa esta obligación significa que
tenía que tendríamos con mi padre y el
alternativo que mi madre nos propuso fue
de alquilar película
como sabrá en ese momento las películas
sólo estaban disponibles en vhs no
existían los dividirlos bluray de los
servicios de streaming que hay hoy en
día
y para nosotros era fantástico eso
porque en cada vida al videoclub
clavamos hasta 6 películas
luego pensando y analizando quiero que
así fue como el cine empezó a volverse
una parte esencial de mi vida y de ahí
de a poco esta idea de yo querer contar
historias de alguna forma recrear esas
emociones que yo tenía cuando veía una
buena película
a cabo el colegio y un poco después
entre la escuela de cine
y la persona que se vio directamente
afectada con esta decisión fue mi santa
madre
y digo directamente afectada porque en
ese momento ella no sabía pero
terminaría trabajando a la fuerza y
gratis en mis primeros cortometrajes
pero mi madre siempre me apoyó en todo
tanto así que terminó colaborando
incluso en los cortometrajes de mis
amigos y descubriendo que actuar era lo
que ella disfrutaba mucho
esto último me alegro mucho a mí
aprovechando que ya estaba con todas
estas intenciones de tomar la actuación
en serio y en mi afán de hacerla ver
cierto tipo de películas que sabía que
otras formas no las iba a ver
empecé a llevar a mi madre al cine
y es muy interesante porque a veces no
nos damos cuenta
pero esto de ir a el cine / salir de la
casa ir a la sala entrar a ver la
película y quizá luego comer algo
terminamos pasando compartiendo hasta
cuatro horas con una persona con un
grupo de personas y con mi madre
aprovechamos todo ese tiempo para
conversar
con el tiempo empecé a notar que algo
muy particular pasaba luego de que
salíamos de ver una película
por alguna razón ella lograba expresarse
con más confianza en nuestras
conversaciones se volvían más íntimas
generalmente hablábamos de cosas
relacionadas a la película que
acabábamos de ver pero muchas veces eran
cosas personales ideas y pensamientos
muy profundos que ya en ese momento
estaba dispuesta a compartirla
y es una parte muy importante para
conectarte con otras personas la
vulnerabilidad y las películas logran
esto de una forma muy sutil nos ponen
vulnerables emocionalmente
no les ha pasado alguna vez que están
viendo una película sin previo aviso sin
sospechar la
descubrirse llorando desconsoladamente o
riendo carcajada o sintiéndose muy
asustado
emociones que hemos aprendido a no
tenerlas o evitarlas en el día a día
porque demuestran vulnerabilidad quizás
alguien podría aprovecharse de eso
bueno estas murallas emocionales que
generamos
y desaparece momentáneamente cuando
vemos una buena película
baja la defensa y empezamos a sentir
intensamente
todo esto me ayudó me ayudó a entender
que mi madre que en la casa siempre
estaba en el papel de madre la que nunca
se cansa la que lo sabe todo lo que
siempre está de buen humor pues mi madre
era como otro ser humano común y
corriente que si se cansa si tiene días
buenos y malos tiene sus complejos sus
preocupaciones y sin querer cuando vamos
al cine generamos este espacio donde nos
podíamos conocer mejor pero no solamente
como madre e hijo sino como sissi y uno
dos personas que nos unen lazo de sangre
pero a diferencia de ella que me conoce
desde que nací yo recién está empezando
a conocerla
entonces regresamos al año 2008 y me
encuentro yo llevando mi padre al cine
tal como él lo hacía cuando yo era chico
y mi padre bueno a diferencia a mi madre
que mi madre es muy expresiva y muy
emocional y reacciona de todo mi padre
era un tipo muy tranquilo muy serio de
pocas expresiones entonces como estamos
viendo una película siempre me gustaba
como espiral o un poquito así de vez en
cuando para ver qué te pasaba en el no
y luego obviamente lo más importante la
charla post película
esa con la excusa de un cafecito una
comidita nos poníamos a conversar
primero de la película porque quería
saber qué sintió que le pareció o no
y luego empezábamos a hablar de los
temas que se tocaron en la película y
para mí esto es muy importante porque
los temas de las películas pueden llevar
a una conversación a lugares muy
interesantes
por ejemplo
amistad lealtad infidelidad homofobia
bullying estos temas y muchos otros más
se tocan en las películas y hablar de
estos temas genera preguntas incómodas y
se expuestas bien con ganas
esto es claro por qué
esto es lo que nos ayuda a conocer a la
otra persona
y a mí esto me ayudó a conocer historias
de mi padre
como por ejemplo como el recordaba
los sonidos de los aviones de guerra que
pasaban encima de su casa en época de
dictadura
o como él cuando era joven tenía un
montón de amigos porque él acostumbraba
armar grandes fiestas
o como él cuando yo era adulto
termino cuidando a su padre a mi abuelo
totalmente solo en sus últimos días
en esta historia y muchas otras más
surgían de nuestras vidas al cine y todo
esto me ayudó a conocerlo mucho más a él
yo amaba al padre
y aprendí a amarlo mucho más
a perdonarlo a que me perdone a
conocerlo como alberto y que él me
conozca como uri cuando vivamos el cine
yo era todo para él idea todo para mí
mi padre falleció el 31 de marzo del año
ocho años después de su regreso a
bolivia
murió mientras dormía murió en paz
y a pesar del dolor que sentí y siento
por haber perdido mi padre
repentinamente
me quedaba la tranquilidad de que pude
llegar a conocerlo y amarlo tal y como
era
y de que él pudo conocerme más
gracias a estos escapes que teníamos
cuando íbamos al cine
desarrollar empatía
[Música]
requiere esfuerzo
no es fácil requiere tiempo y esfuerzo
es como un músculo mientras más
ejercicio mejor
y siempre va a ser clave la persona que
dé el primer paso
pensaba
las películas
yo sé que para todas las películas son
tan normales a ver películas es tan
normal que no es especial no hacemos una
ceremonia
alrededor de una película a su visión ag
así nomás de hecho la mayoría ni
siquiera se cuestiona cómo se hacen las
películas
pero ahora más que nunca las películas
están al alcance de todos
podemos verla incluso nuestro celular
entonces por qué no aprovechamos estos
momentos de ver películas para
desarrollar empatía
llevemos a nuestros padres al cine
paguemos les su entrada si es necesario
o mejor aún veamos algo en casa
preparemos alguna comida y compartamos
una película con nuestro hijo pequeño
veamos cómo se generan preguntas en él y
estemos ahí firmes dispuesto a responder
las de la mejor manera
que las películas no sean sólo
entretenimiento solo para pasar el
tiempo que las películas podamos usarlas
como algo que nos pueda ayudar a
acercarnos más los unos a los otros
las grandes películas por sí sola
nos engrandecen nos civil izan nos hacen
más decente
compartir la potencia su poder
y qué bonito llegar a este punto
de estar frente a la persona que
aprecias y sentir esto de
yo te veo te escucho y te siento y por
qué me importas voy a querer para ti lo
que quiero para mí gracias
[Aplausos]